after rising to fame getting on a big
blockbuster or starring on a show for
years some actors feel they deserve a
pay raise and sometimes it's what got
them fired but how much was too much can
you really fire the fresh prince in
spider-man keep watching to find out
when fans first saw 1982 star trek ii
the wrath of khan they were likely
confused for a couple of minutes instead
of captain kirk played by william
shatner at the helm the film opens with
a young starfleet officer savic
commanding the crew of the enterprise
this eventually proves to be a
simulation and we learned savic a vulcan
played by kirsty alli in one of her
first roles is a trainee but she leaves
a deep impression in that first scene
and throughout the rest of the film
savic appears twice more in the film
series but without ally in 1984 star
track 3 the search for spock in 1986 is
star trek iv the voyage home it's robin
curtis who steps into the role and then
the character disappears forever so what
happened to the original savic according
to ally in her 2016 interview with star
trek.com it wasn't so much that she
asked for more but that she was offered
less ali said that never made sense to
me like you're not paying as much as the
first one and it's a bigger role she
added that in spite of her asking quote
sort of gently the reason for the
lowball she never got an answer and was
replaced without
explanation tank played by marcus chong
is one of the few members of the
nebuchadnezzar's crew to survive the
events of 1999 to the matrix but unlike
the other three survivors tank doesn't
show up in either of the sequels and the
story of why swerves into bizarre
territory the writer director team of
the wachowskis wanted chong to reprise
the role of tank and sources differ on
what he was offered in chong's own 45
minute youtube documentary the marcus
chong story he says the wachowskis
offered him 250 thousand dollars to
appear in 2003's the matrix reloaded and
the matrix revolutions other sources put
the figure at 400 000
regardless neither amount was enough for
chong who wanted one million dollars
when the wachowskis said no chong
resorted to a strange negotiation
strategy chong had a lawyer send a
letter to the wachowskis in which he
asked either for five hundred thousand
dollars or he would do the work for free
apparently the wachowskis had enough
because they chose option three and had
tank killed off screen between movies
in the aftermath chong unsuccessfully
sued the wachowskis their production
company eon warner brothers and aol time
warner he was also arrested for
allegedly making threatening phone calls
to the filmmakers
after the red skull surprised everyone
by appearing on the distant planet
vormir in 2018 avengers infinity war it
may have also surprised a lot of fans
that it was not hugo weaving playing the
spectral guide though he originated the
role in 2011's captain america the first
avenger ross marquand of the walking
dead fame had taken over as early as a
year after the first avenger was
released in theaters weaving told
collider he had no interest in reprising
the role saying i think i've done my
dash with that sort of film it was good
to do it and try it out but to be honest
it's not the sort of film i seek out and
really am excited by acknowledging he
signed a multi-picture deal weaving
insisted he didn't think marvel would
try to force the matter if he said no it
turns out however that weaving was
willing to reprise the role of red skull
for infinity war and its 2019 follow-up
avengers end game however it wound up
being marvel studios who tried to change
the terms of the actor's multi-picture
deal in 2020 he told timeout that marvel
lowballed him in their renegotiations
while weaving didn't give precise
figures he said marvel offered him much
less for the two films
the late valerie harper was a successful
sitcom star throughout the 70s she rose
to fame on the mary tyler moore show
eventually earning her own spin-off
series wrote up she let her own series
again in the 80s nbc's valerie in which
she played a mother trying to raise
three sons mostly on her own with her
husband michael an airline pilot who's
often away for work coincidentally the
series also proved an early high point
in the career of a young jason bateman
who played valerie's eldest son david
valerie proved a hit and in season two
harper decided to take advantage of the
situation originally receiving fifty six
thousand seven hundred fifty dollars per
episode according to people along with
ten percent of the show's adjusted gross
profits harper asked for a significant
bump to one hundred thousand dollars per
episode and 35 of the adjusted gross
profits when nbc said no harper stopped
showing up for work nbc came back with a
counter 65 000 per episode and 12.5 even
still they apparently didn't plan to pay
her that for very long because she was
fired after filming only one more
episode her character was killed off and
the show was first renamed valerie's
family and eventually the hogan family
in july 2012 jennifer lopez told the
world she was leaving her position as
judge on american idol she broke the
news on ryan seacrest's radio show on
the air just a day after aerosmith
frontman steven tyler announced his own
exit from the show at the time jlo told
seacrest she was leaving because idol
was monopolizing her time explaining i
honestly feel like the time has come
that i have to get back to doing the
other things that i have to do it's been
a joy for me to sit here and watch this
for so many years thank you
but it wasn't long before word of a
different reason for lopez's departure
emerged according to the rap lopez
wasn't leaving to devote more time to
other pursuits she was fired the site
claimed that the performer who was
reportedly earning 15 million dollars as
an american idol judge felt she was
underpaid and wanted 17 million dollars
according to the raps source lopez was
let go after asking with fox looking to
rework the show because of a steep
decline in ratings of course between her
musical career her acting and more it's
doubtful jlo felt much financial
hardship in the interim but even if she
had it wouldn't matter much she was
rehired the following year and remained
as a judge until the end of the series
time on fox
there remains no official word on
exactly why jaime foxworth's family
matters character disappeared in the
show's fourth season beyond co-creator
william bickley saying it was for quote
budget considerations after mama's
wedding foxworth's character judy was
never seen again rather than recast judy
for the show's five remaining seasons
her existence was utterly forgotten one
persistent rumor puts the blame for her
departure on the doorstep of foxworth's
mother according to an alleged vet
article gwen fox foxworth's mother and
manager demanded more money for her
daughter and instead foxworth's contract
wasn't renewed this has never been
confirmed however it could easily be
what bitly was talking about when he
mentioned budget considerations foxworth
wouldn't work as an actor on television
again and in later years confessed to
difficult struggles including walking a
difficult road to sobriety
by 1982 the action comedy the dukes of
hazzard wasn't only one of the most
watched shows on television it was also
a huge source of ancillary revenue for
producers and cbs according to the new
york times it generated around 125
million dollars in annual sales of
t-shirts toys and lunch boxes as well as
all the money in from premium
advertising rates the show stars actor
john schneider and tom wopat thought
they were largely responsible for the
lucrative popularity of the show and as
such thought they should be more fairly
compensated for their efforts in 1982
the two stars threatened to leave the
show demanding that producer warner
brothers give them a raise in their
salaries and a piece of the
merchandising profits warner brothers
however thought schneider and wopat were
expendable they let the actors leave the
dukes of hazzard and then staged a big
national search to find two new dukes
after auditioning more than 2 000 actors
warner picked byron cherry and
christopher mayer to play coy and vance
duke explaining that bo and luke had
left home and joined nascar warner
miscalculated the popularity of
schneider and willpat with cherry and
mare headlining the dukes of hazzard
fell from number six in the ratings to
number 34 for the 1982-83
season they had little choice but to
lure back schneider and wopat with
substantial pay raises
we know we know toby maguire was in
spider-man 2 along with its follow-up
spider-man 3 but before that could
happen the web shooter needed to be
fired rehired and briefly threatened
with being replaced by jake gyllenhaal
as recounted by screen crush when
mcguire learned how much sony had made
from 2002 spider-man his 4 million
dollar payday seemed far too small a
slice of the pie
so during negotiations maguire did
something many saw as a tactic he didn't
show up he was supposed to report to get
his face and body scanned for the visual
effects of spider-man 2. however maguire
said that due to mild discomfort in his
lower back from an injury sustained
while filming 2003 seabiscuit he
wouldn't be able to show up for work my
back
open my back
rather than suffer what they saw as a
bluff on meguiar's part sony fired him
and soon afterward director sam raimi
and some of the producers met with jake
gyllenhaal about taking over the role
maguire reportedly panicked had his
future father-in-law ron meyer then the
vice chairman of nbc universal run
interference for him and won the coveted
rollback
the godfather was a universally
acclaimed classic of american cinema
that was both a box office blockbuster
and the winner of many academy awards
the sequel was thoroughly welcomed in
theaters in 1974 just two years after
the release of the first film both a
sequel and a prequel the godfather part
2 switches between the continuing
adventures of michael corleone and vito
corleone robert de niro playing the
younger version of the character from
the godfather that won marlon brando an
oscar francis ford coppola director and
co-writer of both films tried to get
brando to return to the franchise and
reprise the role according to the daily
mail in 1973 coppola sent a letter to
brando to plead his case writing marlin
i respect you enormously and if you told
me that you did not want to do it i
would accept that and never mention it
again according to indy wire brando was
scheduled to film his cameo but didn't
show up on the shooting day because he
was in the middle of a financial dispute
with paramount pictures
just weeks after his long-running hit
sitcom the fresh prince of bel air went
off the air will smith got his movie
career off the ground starring as
wisecracking alien-killing fighter pilot
captain stephen hiller in independence
day his sci-fi action thriller became
the highest grossing movie of 1996.
smith zoomed onto the a-list of film
stars becoming one of the top paid
actors in hollywood headlining big money
makers like men in black hancock i am
legend and i robot afterwards smith
wasn't averse to appearing in sequels he
starred in three bad boys movies and
three men in black films even still when
the long-awaited independence day
follow-up independence day resurgence
finally hit theaters in 2016 smith
wasn't in the cast his character captain
hiller was said to have died off screen
sometime before the events of the film
according to the independent director
roland emmerich started putting the
sequel together in 2011 at which time
smith agreed to star in two
continuations for a total of 50 million
dollars that emmerich said made the
actors services quote too expensive
in its first 20 years on the air the
simpsons earned one billion dollars in
profits for fox according to today its
six main voice performers are paid
relatively well for the role in the
series earning as much as four hundred
thousand dollars per episode according
to the hollywood reporter maggie roswell
served as a supporting member of the
simpsons voice cast appearing frequently
as auxiliary characters notably holier
than now neighbor lady maud flanders as
of the 11th season of the simpsons in
1999 to 2000 roswell's appearances grew
more infrequent until she disappeared
entirely it all ended with mod flanders
violent shocking and darkly comic death
she falls off a racetrack grandstand
when hit by a projectile from a t-shirt
cannon according to the los angeles
times fox said roswell left the show
because she'd grown tired of commuting
from her home in denver to simpson's
production facilities in southern
california roswell disputed that
claiming she asked for a raise from her
standard fifteen hundred dollars to two
thousand dollars per episode fee to six
thousand dollars fox offered an
additional 150 dollars per paycheck so
she quit as that some didn't even cover
the cost of a plane ticket from denver
to la
the late tv show creator gary marshall
ended his career by directing a trio of
ensemble romantic comedies with multiple
intersecting plot lines that take place
around holidays before mother's day and
new year's eve he kicked off the
unofficial trilogy with valentine's day
starring a slew of big names this
included julia roberts anne hathaway
bradley cooper jennifer garner topher
grace and patrick dempsey not among the
cast dempsey's grey's anatomy co-star
catherine heigl in may 2009 page six
reported that heigl was slated to appear
in valentine's day but during salary
negotiations she and her team asked for
a three million dollar fee an insider on
the movie said that such a figure was
ridiculous they claimed that every
performer on the project would be
filming for no more than two weeks and
that no other actors asked for nearly
that amount ultimately producers went in
a non-heigl direction as one of the top
grossing stars in the world and for more
than 30 years at that tom cruise is
generally a go-to guy for a hollywood
movie studio this is especially true if
they want to spend a ton of money on a
big budget stunts and effects heavy
action movie in 2008 on the heels of a
third mission impossible entry and a
remake of war of the worlds cruz was
circling his next project a high-octane
spy thriller for columbia pictures
called edwin a salt according to variety
cruz was willing to portray the title
character a cia operative accused of
being an enemy sleeper agent who must
evade pursuant authorities and clear his
name however he wanted a sizable fee for
his acting services a whopping 20
million dollars colombia's parent
company sony balked at the price tag and
backed away from cruz the studio
ultimately hired angelina jolie and
reworked edwin a salt into salt a film
which earned nearly 300 million dollars
at the global box office oddly enough
according to the new york post jolie
earned for salt exactly what crews had
asked for 20 million dollars
one of cbs's most recognizable and
enduring brands the tropical set crime
procedural hawaii five-o originally ran
from 1968 to 1980 afterward a reboot
returned to typically high ratings from
2010 to 2020 similar to cbs's many other
crime shows the new 5-0 was an ensemble
series about a tight-knit law
enforcement team two of which were
actors daniel day kim and grace park
with production about to start on season
8 and 2017 kim and park entered contract
renewal negotiations teaming up in hopes
of getting a better deal according to
the hollywood reporter kim and park
asked for raises that would bring them
to a salary at or very close to those of
other cast members however cbs refused
to give the actors what they wanted so
they quit the show a cbs insider assured
thr that race wasn't a factor in paying
kim and park less but the actors weren't
so sure kim wrote on facebook i
encourage us all to look beyond the
disappointment of this moment to the
bigger picture park was a bit more
diplomatic telling ew that there were a
number of factors that contributed to
her exit but that she ultimately walked
away because it was best for her
integrity
after quietly premiering in 2000 csi
would become one of the most popular and
most imitated shows on television the
ensemble crime procedural about forensic
investigators in las vegas was the
second most watched drama on tv by the
end of the 2003 2003-2004 tv season
shortly after original cast members
george eads and georgia fox found
themselves fired from the franchise
launching series according to people fox
and edes were under contract with cbs
and the network wished to extend
offering a raise of twenty thousand
dollars per episode each when fox and
eids didn't show up to shoot a csi
episode in july 2004 network executives
took that as a sign of silent protest
that the pay bump was insufficient cbs's
response to the no-shows was firing edes
and fox but they re-hired them two weeks
later at their old salaries cancelling
the 20 000 per episode raises
in the first decade of the 2000s few
people were as famous or omnipresent as
paris hilton part of the mega wealthy
hilton family she became famous for
being a conventionally attractive
club-hopping scenester who parlayed her
visibility into a hit fox reality show
the simple life hilton also made a sex
tape that was leaked online establishing
a persona as a disaffected primadonna
hilton even filed a trademark for her
oft muttered catchphrase that's hot
hilton was just about at the peak of her
fame and influence in 2009 when she
secured a small role in the other guys a
police comedy starring will ferrell and
mark wahlberg an insider on the movie
told page six that while hilton's part
amounted to a cameo the celebrities
representatives delivered a hefty list
of requirements for the client among
hilton's needs for her one day shoot
were live lobsters to be cooked at a
moment's notice and top shelf gray goose
vodka the director ultimately cut
hilton's appearance from the theatrical
cut of the other guys entirely check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one